what were some of the first steps you
took i mean did you go to actors access
and put up a casting notice or what did
you
okay so the first thing was to
secure locations because we had this
i wrote the script in a way that could
be
possible to do in real life
and and so we were able to secure the
avenue of the stars for example for one
day of shoot
and i went and see people at ucla which
was tough to secure because even though
i was a student at ucla extension but
still student ucla it's still
super hard to get authorization and
permits
and because they're more into uh
authorizing
shows like csi
so so great shows and kind of uh
great indie movies like uh i don't like
like studio indie movies talking and not
no budget so
it was kind of hard but because we
talked about the story and about
uh what i wanted to do and what
locations i needed
uh
they were fine with it and
so after the locations at the same time
as locations we started the
what for me was the most important
process which is
the casting
the audition process
and for me that was the most important
because since i knew i was going to rely
a lot on improv i needed to have the
right people and because this story is
a character driven story before all i
knew that
my characters my actors
would have to carry the film
and and at the end i knew that they
would be
creating this the film
as me as i was doing on set so
so i auditioned these people
here at film independent
and we had uh
two days of full
auditions and we saw
almost 1 000 people and it was crazy
tons of people boys and girls from for
the boys and girls roles and and each
time we i mean
all these people
were
hired because i had
a true
i fell in love with them for the
characters
they were the right character
and so it was it wasn't fun and and very
enjoyable process i love auditioning
casting it's great because you meet
these people who are going to bring
something else
to the game to the character i mean a
lot of people
brought
so much to the character that at the end
of the day the character changed and so
that was the most beautiful thing i
think
you